hello there you're watching the press
preview of first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the new statesman's political
editor there they are stephen bush and
the spectators economics correspondent
kate andrews but first
let's see what's on some of those front
pages the metro leads with an apology
from health secretary sajid javid for
tweeting that people should no longer
cower from covet a statement that many
twitter users insisted was disrespectful
to those
who have lost their lives to the virus
the guardian claims an exclusive with a
warning from doctors that increasing
numbers of young people are being
admitted to hospital with covid
and urging youngsters to get the vaccine
the telegraph reports that union leaders
are fighting government plans to end the
ping demk
which could cause problems for shoppers
holidaymakers and commuters
the mail reports that as many as 50 000
new cases of dementia went undiagnosed
last year in large part
because referrals to memory clinics were
stopped
because of the pandemic the ft
understands the government is looking at
ways to stop the chinese state-owned
nuclear energy group from being
involved in any future uk projects in
the sector
while the star claims that oh breaking
wind can spread co-fit oh delightful
well we're joined tonight by stephen
bush and kate andrews
thanks a lot for joining us let's not
cover that one um
let's however start with um the daily
mail
this is this is something that we're
going to deal with dealing with for
decades isn't it the fallout
from the pandemic kate you want to just
take us through this
um the covert dementia disaster
yeah the front page of the mail today as
well as many of its inside pages
is highlighting um many of the medical
problems that have
developed over the course of the past 16
months
as patients were not properly diagnosed
due to the situation that we were in um
and the male front page is highlighting
that one in ten
new sufferers from dementia are thought
to have gone
uh undiagnosed and they think this could
amount to
50 000 cases if you look elsewhere in
the mail they're looking at
strokes heart attacks and the fewer
hospital emissions that took place
over the course of the past 12 months
due to a series of restrictions and and
lockdowns and
this echoes what the new health
secretary sajid javid said a few weeks
ago about how they
suspect that um over seven million uh
people
did not come forward for some kind of
ailment and it is a stark reminder of
the
ketchup that we're going to have to play
but also very sadly there are
going to be many people whether they're
dementia sufferers cancer sufferers
and the rest of it um who are going to
have a very different trajectory
with their ailment now because they
didn't get care
as soon as they needed it these are the
harsh realities of the trade-offs that
we've had to face
nobody wanted to see the health service
overwhelmed
that would have been very frightening
for a myriad of reasons and yet
we know that possibly millions of people
have gone
under diagnosed or undiagnosed during
this time
and um that is going to be the
repercussions of that are going to be
with us for many years to come
and the problem with so many of these
conditions is that um help is most
effective
the earlier you get it isn't it um
stephen just
one line i'm i'm reading uh there on the
front of the daily mail it is fear that
even more cases will be missed if virus
restrictions
return in autumn or winter i mean this
is something that some people are saying
isn't it that we may
be in lockdown again if things don't go
well for us and what do you think about
that line
well yeah this this is the the fear
right and then the government's
approach right through this pandemic has
been essentially to be as
open as they think they can get away
with before nhs capacity keels over
now if it turns out then we've got that
balance slightly wrong and nhs capacity
does keel over then of course the only
way that you prevent the sort of
collapse of health care systems
is for us all to go back into lockdown
however the thing i think is important
to note about that line is
while it is undoubtedly true that during
the lockdown
people didn't get medical treatment than
they should have gone um
at no point were people being told not
to seek medical help
for things they they needed that that
was an example of people going
further than the law and further than
guidance suggested which i think does
show how it's very important for
politicians and all of us in in any form
of public eye to be careful about how we
talk about the next lockdown because
it's clear that a large number of people
thought they were doing what they had to
do by avoiding getting important
um medical treatment and import and
getting things checked out
during lockdown one and lock down two
when um
the reason we have lockdowns uh even
though they're awful and we should try
and avoid them
is precisely to preserve healthcare
capacity so people can have
those all important um health healthcare
emergencies
to keep getting checked even if you find
it a bit difficult to see your gp just
keep
trying um let's let's stay on this story
but look at
page eight of the mail because
um this says as cases plunge again
are we past the peak of the third wave
and they're saying it's the first time
cases have fallen below thirty thousand
thirty thousand since july the sixth
and the last five day run of falling
numbers was in february
shortly after the uk passed the peak of
the winter wave
um kate what do you make of this because
these figures
don't take into account what's happened
in the last week
do they i mean the figures they're
delayed a bit aren't they
yes they are delayed so they're not
reflecting the
reopening on the 19th of july so-called
freedom day
um but look on the face of it good news
there could be a myriad of reasons for
the spike of course we had the euros we
had significant social mingling
indoors and out around the euros and so
this
peak could have been reflecting that
surge in cases due to the football
um it's also thought that the reopening
on the 17th of may in
england would have triggered a
significant rise in infections because
that was the moment that people started
socializing again and moving
indoors and we know that this virus is
most likely to spread
in enclosed spaces with poor ventilation
and so that move indoors
a lot of people think we've actually had
a bigger impact than perhaps what we're
going to see
from the 19th of july but we have to
keep an open mind it's
great news that cases are going down um
but you know this virus does continue to
surprise us and we may well
see an another spike due to this recent
reopening
the really good news however is that as
cases have been going up
hospitalizations have remained about a
quarter
of what they were when we saw previous
peaks in this virus
showing the link between infection and
hospitalization
and has been severely uh suffered i
think not
completely but quite notably severed
thanks back then so uh we
are able to deal with in a different way
now let's stick with that
um but look at the guardian because
they say they have this exclusive that
young people they're urging them to
they're being urged to get the jobs by
doctors
because doctors are saying that icu
admissions
younger people more and more younger
people are being admitted to icu with
covid um stephen what do you make of
this
well um this is obviously an important
story and it's why um you know
why everyone should uh get a jab as soon
as they're offered one
but we would expect this because
although um
the piranha virus affects the elderly
much more severely and in much greater
numbers
um you know one percent of a very big
number which is the total number of
young people in the uk
is still a very big number and it's a
number then
um you know even though most people even
most people who young people with covert
who go into icu
will come back out again um it's still
icu capacity than is being taken out of
commission and because the disease
spreads so um
you know spread so easily in confined
settings it also has a much
bigger effect on icu capacity because if
i'm in an icu bed with kovid
and someone's in a car accident they
don't have covet they can't then be in
the icu bed next to me because i might
give them covet at a time when they're
already very vulnerable so this is a
reminder that um
just because um those of us who are
lucky to be
under median age are more likely to be
fine
it doesn't mean that um there aren't
impacts for ourselves and also impacts
for
society as a whole if people sort of
take the message from that then
oh well i'll wait for my jab until you
know i'm 45 50 at an age when i need to
keep
myself kate what do you think professor
adam finn from
jcvi has said um they've been close to
200 admissions
with a mean age of 40 in the city um
university of bristol
that's during the delta variant wave um
do you think
this sort of a headline this sort of a
story an exclusive from the guardian
will actually get people
out and getting their jabs
look i think it helps to highlight it
but i think steven put it into
perspective
very well the young people who are going
into the icu are more likely to come out
of the icu so we have to
you know keep that broader picture in
mind but nobody wants to go into the icu
nobody should want to get covet it's a
nasty virus and even though
the people who are taking up the vaccine
slower are in this younger age group
nobody really wants to get it it's
really important to get your job and
also to get that
follow second one uh follow up second
one to make sure that you are
to make sure you're fully protected we
are seeing a slower uptake now
amongst young people i do think
headlines like this um
you know you don't want to overstate you
don't want to understate really you want
to educate about
the value of the vaccine the safety of
the vaccines and why it's important to
get it not just for yourself
um but to help the community around you
too um but yeah
i think stephen put it into perspective
well these people are much more likely
to come out of the icu
it is not like what we were seeing last
year when there were no vaccines
available
but let's try to avoid that situation
completely if you have
a working vaccine that is a much better
option than finding yourself in a
situation where you're unlikely to be
very sick
but you could be and that could you know
prove very harmful down the road
yeah okay um we're going to take a break
stephen k
see you in a minute um coming up why is
the government looking to stop chinese
state involvement
in the uk's nuclear energy projects
we're going to be discussing that
hello again you're watching the press
preview with me now stephen bush and
kate andrews
hello again to you both um the financial
times this is interesting
um ministers are trying to ditch chinese
a chinese partner that they have in a
nuclear program and this of course comes
after um the foreign secretary said that
the uk can no longer conduct business as
usual with beijing
stephen yeah this is a really important
story in on several fronts the first
first reason is of course yeah for most
of the last decade we've had
a very open policy as far as chinese
investment
chinese money and relative proximity to
the chinese state
now of course um the reality is is
proximity to chinese businesses is the
same as proximity to
the chinese state because that is
essentially the condition of carriage if
you are a business
operating in china but as a result of a
number of things
covered in part but in large part
actually due to the repression of hong
kong
um the british government now finds
itself at odds with the chinese
government with a parliamentary party
that
very much thinks they should be going
further and
yeah you can argue about whether it's
the right policy but it is a policy with
quite big costs
one of which um will be the future of
various nuclear projects
and making them slightly more difficult
than they have been perhaps in the past
and um this is kind of i think in some
ways the first big sign that the
government is willing to make um
actions max words it's interesting
because you say
that that is um you know how things
operate in beijing but huawei have
always said
we are the chinese government we aren't
the chinese government haven't they kate
well yes they have the connections are
clearly there and as steven says if
you're dealing with big business in
china it's almost guaranteed to be
wrapped up in the
ccp in some capacity and uh
you know the the pushback on wall
playing its connection to the 5g network
would naturally
extend then to nuclear energy especially
when we're thinking about something
so fundamental to the uk infrastructure
but if you speak to certain tory mp
concerned about the state of the
finances this is again where really
difficult trade-offs come in
because if the government wants to hit
its 2050 target of net zero
and it's well aware the uk here isn't
going to be able to pay for every single
penny of that
it's going to get serious about nuclear
and it's going to be have to
look for from the private sector but as
that's the big question around this you
know it's not like dealing with normal
aspects of the private sector
business that is wrapped up in the ccp
and that is clearly something that's
changed very quickly
you're looking element it's attitude
towards business and the government in
china